moi je vous dis allez première question
comment devoir faire allez la première
question qui va s'afficher sur votre
écran que vont devoir faire les
visiteurs pour assister je sais pas si
vous avez vu passer cet acte a une
exposition en Angleterre alors
franchement je sais je tire un maillot
de l'Angleterre se frotter à des
personnes nues trop réponse B payé à
leur entrée en sous-vêtements ou porter
un masque de Bertrand nickel
je vais y aller souvent alors maintenant
ça demande ça fera Daniel alors il se
frottait alors
souvent réponse
c'est
français des personnes c'est pour
rentrer dans l'exposition il y a un
homme et une femme nue là en face de
l'autre et il faut il faut vraiment
regarder l'image c'est quand même
incroyable vous êtes pas obligé si vous
rentrez l'exposition vous avez le choix
vous avez une entrée normale ou cette
entrée ça va s'afficher sur sur votre
écran vous êtes obligé de passer entre
deux personnes l'une exposition se
déroulent
à la Royal Academy of hearts allons
regarder l'extrait
depuis ce week-end les œuvres de
l'artiste serbe Marina Abramovitch sont
exposés à la Royal Academy
et pour les observer les visiteurs
devront entrer d'une manière
particulière en se faufilant entre deux
personnes complètement nues en
effleurant leur partie intime cette
performance artistique force une
confrontation entre la nudité le genre
la sexualité et le désir mais pour les
visiteurs qui ont du mal avec cette
performance déjà réalisée en 1977 ils
pourront toujours passer par une autre
entrée sans avoir cette fois à se
glisser entre deux cornes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
trop grave le seul but le seul but c'est
de choquer et moi ce qui me choque le
bus c'est qu'on réduise à l'esclavagiste
c'est de personnes ces deux
intermittents qui pour bosser sont
obligés de se mettre à poil et de se
faire frotter par des touristes
allemands dans une exposition où je
trouve pas le matin c'est un courant
artistique très fort qui s'appelle l'arc
corporel et d'ailleurs elle était à la
Biennale de Venise en 97 ouais c'est
enfermé c'est sûr que c'est violent
c'est c'est provoquant c'est choquant
c'est volontaires c'est de l'art c'est
une forme d'art on aime on n'aime pas
attends j'ai pas fini et là elle s'enfer
dans un espèce de cagibi à la binal de
Venise en 97 c'était assez choquant elle
était sur des eaux sanguinolant etc et
en fait c'est une femme qui est
traumatisée par la guerre en Yougoslavie
et et elle le traduit comme ça ça sort
de ça sinon on fait ça sur un plateau
la définition de là elle est très
compliqué
d'abord c'est comme l'a dit Gilles on
n'est pas obligé donc il y a pas
d'injonction comme ça voilà et je trouve
que c'est très intéressant et de toute
façon aujourd'hui on est dans une époque
totalement rétrograde qui est choquée
pour tout et pour n'importe quoi et on
veut une police de l'art une police de
l'humour une police des bonnes blagues
ça n'est pas possible
moi je trouve que c'est très bien il y a
une mise en abyme justement de la nudité
moi par exemple il y a j'aime bien le
vagin par exemple de cap pour euh
j'aime bien le plug blason j'ai pas dit
que ça c'était c'était forcément bien ça
doit pas plaire mais ça doit choquer ça
doit pas plaire là et fait pour être
subversif et arrêter tout le temps de
vouloir tout contrôler en mettant des
bons points et des mauvais points c'est
insupportable moi je suis pas d'accord
avec Guillaume parce que ces deux
personnes si elles sont là et qu'elle
travaille ici je pense que déjà c'est me
regarde pas en rigolant parce que j'ai
envie de rire aussi ces deux personnes
elles sont dans le bain elles sont dans
l'histoire de cette exposition elles ont
des connaissances elles sont là elles
savent pourquoi elles sont là après ce
que je reproche à Géraldine c'est que
toi tu passerais entre ces deux
personnes de manière habillée moi si j'y
vais j'y vais je passe à
poils
[Applaudissements]
et après vous visitez à poil
l'exposition ouais c'est un peu avant
tout l'exposition non bah
oui mais pour être égaux avec ces
personnes et justement qui est pas ce
symbole de l'humiliation
c'est ça justement le le en fait
l'expérience sensorielle c'est d'être
habillé et de passer entre deux
personnes plus de sensations et deux
points et de maintenant et de voir
justement ce que ça la nudité de l'autre
alors que toi tu portes des vêtements
c'est ça l'expérience je suis pas sûr
qu'il casse à poils qui est sensible tu
passes pas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous passez ou pas entre les deux alors
moi je dis claire c'est comme l'humour
j'avais déjà fait moi en tant que en
tant que
je
répondeur
je pense que je laisserai tranquille
surtout que si un courant d'air je pense
que les deux tombent malades
[Applaudissements]
question comme les gens beaux comme
Kelly
[Applaudissements]
le
deuxième question deuxième question que
sont en train de faire depuis 36 jours
des monténégrin réponse a un concours
d'apnée vous allez voir réponse B une
partie de pétanque réponse et un
inventaire de toutes les fringues moches
de viande désolé c'est pas moi
de flemme est-ce que vous avez vu c'est
ces images alors qui a la réponse Gilles
ils sont là ils sont allongés ils ont
une pause de temps en temps et le but
c'est d'aller plus loin possible et
gagner 1000 euros voilà alors
les images où on parle après regarde
1000 € pour rester rallongé non vous ne
rêvez pas bienvenue au concours de la
flemme du petit village de Brenna au
Monténégro après plus d'un mois de
sieste acharnée ils sont désormais plus
que 4 finalistes parmi eux Lee Jah
esthéticienne qui a déjà passé plus de
800 heures au repos mon frère et mes
parents sont venus me supplier d'arrêter
en me promettant 1000 euros en échange
mais je leur ai dit qu'il n'y avait
aucune chance que j'arrête et que je
resterai jusqu'au bout pour le plus
grand bonheur des organisateurs cette
année est un excellent cru puisque le
record de la flemme a été largement
dépassé jusqu'à ce jour la plus longue
sieste des candidats avait duré 5 jours
soit prêt de 117
[Applaudissements]
c'est qui le plus gros flemmard autour
de la table franchement
[Rires]
je suis hyperactif tu faisais pas de
sport déjà pour commencer
j'ai dit ça
c'est bien possible je suis hyper actif
c'est un problème tu vois si je sais si
j'ai rien à faire un jour je suis pas
une idée
[Rires]
ma vie mais je vous laisse fantasmer
mais à quoi on mesure la paresse moi
c'est ça qui me paresseuse Jacques en
fait est-ce que je trouve
son temps de lire de lire au lit
super tard mais est-ce que c'est ça la
paresse c'est pour ça parce que je
trouve que ce jeu il a il a il a aucun
intérêt parce que c'est un rapport avec
ça c'est pas ça tu mesures pas la
paresse au fait de rester au lit 30
heures ou 40 heures ou 5h c'est vraiment
c'est la fin
parce qu'à partir du moment où mais si
on dit par exemple aujourd'hui bah ok là
tu vas pas gagner 1000 euros mais tu vas
gagner 250000 euros ou un million à ce
moment-là je pense que tout le monde
veut bien jouer le jeu voilà
c'est ça le public va s'endormir on va
proposer ça donne rien faire pendant un
an deux ans trois ans quatre ans 250000
c'est pas grave mais l'origine de la
compétition vient d'une blague voilà une
blague qu'est-ce que vous disais à
propos des démonter
en France je sais pas en tout cas 1000 €
à gagner ils ont droit au téléphone et à
la tablette on en parlera tout à l'heure
dans un autre sujet je sais pas si vous
avez vu hier zone interdite et les
ravages des tablettes et des écrans n'en
parlera tout à l'heure question 3 en
français de 18 ans a réussi l'exploit
d'obtenir quelque chose mais quoi
réponse a une date avec Kendall Jenner
réponse B sur pilotage d'avion de ligne
réponse C son doctorat en médecine
réponse d un pain pardon
[Applaudissements]
non mais surtout avec mon nom il s'écrit
un peu pareil c'est pour ça
et j'étais avec mon chien
je disais mais je sais de la parole à
Pharo qui va vous dire bonjour aussi tu
vois le truc
[Musique]
bonjour C'est Dorothée je me souviens
très bien
c'était vraiment la mode vraiment et ils
en ont ils en ont hyper cher
j'en ai plein parce que moi j'ai jamais
osé le
porterait ce soir mince
je ne savais pas alors la réponse qui a
la réponse
il est très jeune c'est un côté cent
mille euros payé par ses proches il
franchit les étapes à l’ègrement son
rêve c'est de conduire un immense Airbus
mais déjà c'est incroyable ce qu'il a
fait quoi parce que il a à 18 ans jamais
du jamais vu en Europe c'est c'est fou
avec des passagers jeune homme s'appelle
gouaric Landry il a 18 ans et tout
simplement à l'heure actuelle et bien le
plus jeune pilote d'Europe alors en plus
de tout ça il a obtenu sa licence en un
an seulement au lieu des deux ans
traditionnels il a obtenu à l'école aéro
fut ure de Perpignan mais l'originaire
de Guadeloupe et en fait bah c'était un
rêve de gosse pour lui de piloter des
avions apparemment il aime les
challenges le plus jeune pilote d'Europe
ça lui suffit pas et en termes
d'appareil il rêve de piloter un Airbus
350 et pourrait devenir l'un des plus
jeunes pilotes de l'histoire à piloter
des vols longs
incroyable parcours qui a suivi cette
histoire
[Applaudissements]
c'est incroyable quand même le parcours
donc ça va être un peu difficile à ce
que je dois 18 ans non je fais la
facturer celle-là je pense
un petit blanc non pas 18 ans j'étais à
l'école
[Applaudissements]
imaginez qu'il puisse conduire enfin
merci merci un avion de ligne est-ce que
vous montez encore
je ne sais pas Géraldine dans l'avion
ligne de vous savez pas
il lui manque des heures de vol quand
même donc
[Rires]
un décrochage une simulation de mal en
plein vol il a franchi toutes les essais
normal
qu'on est oui mais c'est normal quand le
test à tous les niveaux pour voir sa
réactivité mais toute confiance
etc mais après on sait très bien que
quand il y a des problèmes par exemple
quand il y avait eu le mec qui avait
posé l'avion là sur l'Hudson River à New
York il disait que s'il avait pas eu le
temps d'expérience en dehors de vol etc
il aurait jamais pu amerrir comme ça
enfin donc moi je suis mais c'est vrai
qu'on a jamais en fait la fiche
signalétique du mec qui est pilote
l'avion on se doute quand même pas 18
ans et qu'il a quand même des heures de
vol derrière lui
c'est hyper codifié tu passes pas à 3,50
à 18 ans il faut attendre pas mal
d'années avant de pouvoir
un pilote de 18 ans et après il y a il y
a même 2 ans bien sûr
23 24 ans 18 ans c'est passé
[Rires]
dans ma chambre
en regardant la télé
d'accord
moi j'étais en prépa HEC
bravo
non non je joue au tennis voilà le
tennis on prépare votre rêve devenir
chef d'entreprise que quand on fait HEC
moi mon rêve c'était non c'est je
voulais être metteur en scène voilà
c'est comme quoi c'est réussi
[Musique]
mon rêve j'étais standardiste Europe 1
et c'était mon rêve
standardiste en fait j'assistais aux
émissions avant quand j'étais gamine et
mon rêve c'était déjà d'être voilà de
travailler
tout le monde a réussi les rêves de 18
ans c'est formidable ça
la télévision ça vous intéresse ce que
je dis non
et je suis journaliste
[Applaudissements]
voilà
allez question 5 il nous reste quoi un
peu plus de 2 minutes pourquoi 2 hackers
sont-ils actuellement jugés à Paris
modifier les prix de l'essence
ils ont piraté des webcams de
particuliers ils ont créé un faux profil
de derrière
alors pourquoi raconter en fait ils ont
alors ce sont des hackers qui ont envoyé
des mails à des particuliers en leur
faisant croire qu'ils avaient des vidéos
de en train de regarder des sites
pornographiques des vidéos qui auraient
été capturées à partir de leurs
ordinateur personnel or c'était faux
mais ils ont réussi à obtenir des
millions d'euros énorme donc ils ont
racketté ces gens là donc petit conseil
chez vous si vous regardez ce type de
film parce que j'ai des amis qui
regardent
un morceau
il y a eu 20 000 signalements et 1300
plaintes et 47 personnes ont payé il y a
47 personnes qui ont payé parce que en
fait quand ils avaient pris à distance
le contrôle si vous tapiez par exemple
site pornographique ou pornographie il
vous filmait avec votre webcam en train
de taper ça et donc du coup
c'est que les gens s'amusaient devant
leur ordinateur en regardant les vidéos
vous voyez ce que je veux dire forcément
il y a un truc je comprends pas c'est
que tout le monde regarde des films
porno et tout donc tout le monde peut
s'entendre
des films porno
[Rires]
en ce moment qu'on reçoit par mail qui
dit voilà vous êtes convoqué à la
gendarmerie parce que vous avez vous
êtes détenteur de photos
pédopornographiques et je me suis dit
mais quand même hein ce truc à par mail
c'est assez classique et je me suis mais
qui sont concernés en fait à quel moment
tu cliques sur le mail pour dire enfin
il y a peu de gens c'est une niche quand
même heureusement le dire l'histoire qui
est folle aux États-Unis le groupe MGM
casino donc des hackers de Russie des
jeunes ont réussi à s'infiltrer dans le
réseau du groupe MGM en réclamant 30
millions de dollars donc en fait ils ont
déconnecté ils sont rentrés dans le
système ils ont tout déconnecté donc
effectivement les chambres de marché
plus les machines à sous le marché plus
le MGM perdait des millions par jour ils
ont négocié à 30 millions et c'est tombé
à 15 millions ils ont payé la rançon 15
millions de dollars
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire comme si on
se retrouve un jour
on va porter plainte à cyber-harcèlement
et là vous il s'occupe de vous il faut
jamais payer en fait
il y a des négociateurs il y a des
négociateurs dans le cyber dans cyber
dans le dans la King justement et que
ils sont spécialisés justement dans la
négociation pour que les équipes
derrière puisse travailler et gagner du
temps je répète parce que c'est
important cyber-harcèlement.gouv.fr
et non tu vas à la police
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]